and as president biden works to push his
massive spending bill through congress
claiming the richest americans will foot
the bill he's spending as jackie said
the holiday at a billionaire's compound
so is quote middle class joe out of
touch with everyday americans let's
bring in stephen moore former economic
advisor to president trump and founder
of the committee to unleash prosperity
steve happy thanksgiving thanks for
being here you just heard jackie's
report
was this perhaps an oversight what are
the optics here
well greg great to be with you happy
thanksgiving to you too and by the way i
hope the president has a happy
thanksgiving as well and everyone uh
look maybe this wasn't the best optics
but uh the president can can have his
thanksgiving dinner wherever he wants i
think the bigger problem here
is what's happening with the middle
class and the in this rising inflation
grip and there just doesn't seem to be a
solution coming out of this white house
right now uh they in fact they're
pitching a three trillion dollar debt
bill uh that that would actually make
the inflation worse but people are
feeling this you know the the the
interesting thing about when you have
higher inflation which we do right now
it's running at about six percent grip
people feel you know the spin from
washington and the spin from
incontinence don't matter because people
feel it every single day i notice grip i
don't know if you do when i go to the
gas pump now people are grumbling about
how much they're paying it's 20 bucks
more to fill up your tank
this thanksgiving than it was a year ago
yeah and let's look talking about
feeling the pain let's show our viewers
how much you're paying for that turkey
now we know that staples goods at the
grocery store are up 14 but the turkey
itself a 16 pound turkey is 24 i was
telling our producers on a call about an
hour ago i got a 16 pound turkey it cost
me 68 steve this is real pain from the
grocery store to the gas pump how long
does it last and how damaging is it to
this administration
yeah you know you're right about that
and you've got that graphic up there 24
higher for turkey prices this uh this
season and jen pasake i don't know if
you noticed it she said oh people are
paying just a dollar more for a 20 pound
turkey i'm like boy her math i don't get
the math on that because it's you know
four it's four or five or six dollars
more for these turkeys now uh give
based on how how big that bird is uh i
as i said earlier i just don't think
this administration has a a cure for the
inflation they continue to talk about
more debt and more spending from
washington which means flushing more
money in the economy that that could
make the inflation worse and when it
comes to gas prices you know yesterday
in his statement
president biden kept talking about all
these strategies he has for lowering gas
prices but we didn't bring up is all the
policies he has in place that are
raising gas prices grip for example
killing pipelines cancelling existing
pipelines the fact that we they canceled
drilling in alaska that we're not doing
more permitting of lands you know
there's no country in the world grip
that has more oil gas and coal and
energy resources than the united states
we are blessed
with this incredible amount of energy
and natural resources in this country
and i think people are getting a little
frustrated we're not using them we're
not going after them and that's making
us by the way that's making us more
dependent on
saudi arabia russia uh opec countries
that aren't friendly to the united
states
steve before we run out of time you
mentioned jinsaki i believe the moment
you were talking about is when
she was asked a question by our own
peter ducey take a look at this i think
this is the moment you met watch yeah
message doesn't send to the middle class
americans president biden says that he's
trying to help who are struggling this
week to cover the cost of the most
expensive thanksgiving ever that
president is going to take a few days
off at a billionaire's compound in
nantucket
any increase in prices is something the
president is concerned about but i just
want to be clear that there are
abundance of turkeys available they're
about one dollar more for a 20 pound
bird which is a huge bird if you're
feeding a very big family
so from the white house briefing room to
fancy nantucket are they failing to
quote read the room if it were
well i just again i don't know how she
came up with her math there because
people are paying a lot more than a
dollar more for a turkey but then you
know another incident happened this week
where jennifer granholm who is the
energy secretary was asked how much uh
you know do we how much energy do we
consume in terms of barrels of oil a day
and she said i don't know and you know
when you have a secretary of energy who
doesn't know what our energy policies
are just like pete budas doesn't know
anything about he's the transportation
secretary he doesn't know anything about
planes trains and automobiles i mean
it's a problem i think you have people
are a little bit in washington out of
touch
well we'll see if that spr release does
bring prices down steve moore thank you
very much and have a very happy
thanksgiving oh you too
thanks for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else